Listen up y’all.  No need to rush nothing on defense.
Cut-off man, get out there.  Get your cut-off.
Stop them extra bases today. No mistakes.
Small mistakes, let 'em go.
Keep on rolling. Stay focused.
Various: On three. 1,2,3 win.
Who are we? Coast Crips,
Batting order. Parnell, Tyrell, Stan, Little BK, Tiny Dog, etc…T-Dog.  Let’s go
The San Pedro baseball diamond is a neutral site
for these teams of ex-gang members.
Raymond Avenue Crips, Rollin' 90s,
Compton Santana,  East Coast
The competition will be fierce.
They all have something to prove.
Watching intently are UCLA professor emeritus
Wellford ‘Buzz’ Wilms and former Raymond Crip Reynaldo ‘Wiz’ Reaser.
Their collaboration stems from Buzz’s expertise in conflict mediation
and Rey’s desire to correct a problem from the inside-out.
You know the gang life was more of a family.
More of a protection of a community itself.
And at some point it just went way left.
Just violence, senseless violence.
And it was wrong.
Wilms says violence, drugs and guns—
coupled with a deep mistrust of law enforcement
—have allowed street gangs to remain entrenched in their neighborhoods.
A cycle that’s persisted for decades.
The gangs are only a symptom of these communities
that have been so beleaguered for so long.
It’s in the fabric of the neighborhoods.
But Wilms, who has spent years in South LA, also sees
what he calls ‘a new social fabric in the making.’
And it’s weaving together gang members,
cops and UCLA students.
If I had a dream, it’s we’d somehow find a way
to really connect UCLA with South LA.
Because we sit here all by ourselves.
And they sit down there all by themselves
and there are very few bridges between us.
For most of those students, you can say like
“we’re going to…the teacher will say we’re going to call security.”
And the kids are like, “OK ,Cool.” Because they
know exactly where they’re going
and they’d rather stay in the office
than sit in the classroom.
So a big one for me was, how are we able to talk to
these kids without taking them away
from a classroom environment,
which is what they want.
Well, the basics of it came from Avis in 1998.
She trained me, along with 35 other people, as a mediator.
Because the kind of training she did was really good,
I thought what better place for it than the schools.
And then this idea—a light bulb went on in my head—Avis!
I called Avis up and I said, ‘would you be willing
to come to UCLA to co-design and
co-teach a course with me in conflict resolution?
Basically, what you taught me.’
More than 500 undergrads have taken the course.
The first quarter is spent training them in mediation techniques.
The second and the optional third quarter
has the students
assigned to some of the toughest schools in the county.
As I began to wake up to the reality of Los Angeles,
I started talking with Avis.
Let’s focus on South LA because
that’s where the need really is.
Every school has the need but where the need
is really great is in South LA.
Where conflict is part of the air that people breathe.
One team went to Horace Mann Middle School
near Florence and Western.
Another landed at the Manchester Avenue campus
of Soledad Enrichment Action.
Both schools are chaotic to a certain degree.
Because Horace Mann is just starting up
this partnership with UCLA, having lost
the vast majority of its students.
So it took a while for us to get our footing there,
know who we are and what our students can do.
On our very last day they gave us a list of students
and their conflicts.  And we’re kinda like, OK,
we don’t know what to do with this now but
we’ll hand it over to the next mediators;
so, at least they can go in and say “we’re mediators.
Can you give us the list” and they’ll have the list.
Yeah, where at the beginning it was definitely was a little
bit frustrating because, ‘who do we talk to?’
And at the end it was kind of cool because
we did become the leaders of this program.
To try and move forward and do things
the way we wanted to see them be done.
The fact that we have backstories and stuff now
—which is great—
but also when they’re here they need to know
that this is what we’re going to do.
We’re going to sit down and do introductions,
get to know each other.
The team at Horace Mann found themselves doing
much more than just conflict mediation.
They were mentors, advisors and confidants
—sometimes just doing damage control.
At Soledad, which is also known as SEA,
the stakes are higher.
And SEA is just a unique little school that operates with
less than a hundred students.  It’s a charter school.
And they take the kids that have nowhere else to go.
They’ve bombed out of LAUSD.
So we’re dealing with the least-advantaged
students in the whole city.
Our students got experience they would get
in no other way.
We discussed identity, police culture
and dealing with anger.
And the dealing with anger one actually came as a result of…
there was a fight that broke out the day that
we were there on one Thursday.
I was that student when people came in
and tried to do programs in the school.
I was like, ‘what are you doing here, you know.
You don’t know anything about me and you can’t relate
to me.  Why are you trying to impose your stuff on me.
So, definitely it was just a lot of establishing yourself
as a person within the community.
The second floor at SEA has areas set aside
for the mentors, mediators and interventionists
working to reduce gang crime and violence.
In one room, tacked up on the bulletin board
are funeral programs.
Young victims from neighborhoods
where being outside comes with risks.
Today, Buzz is there to discuss a project with Reynaldo
and Kevin Orange—formerly a Hoover Crip.
When you’re dealing with gang violence, most of
the time it starts with something that’s isolated.
Between two people. They don’t have an understanding.
Or how to resolve a conflict.
But when you have the tools of a mediator you get to
hear and listen to where you can discuss things.
And somebody can say something anywhere that can
cause a whole community to be at war for 40 years.
In 2016, Reynaldo organized a softball tournament with
teams entered from several different neighborhoods—
—some with a long history.
The Pete Carroll Foundation picked up the costs for
uniforms, umpires and playing field rentals.
Well I started this softball tournament to
unite a lot of different neighborhoods together.
But, it’s not particularly for the gangs.
It’s for the community.
Because we want the community
relationship with the gangs.
It was a good start but Reynaldo thought
it could be much more.
What if each team had a trained
mediator—an ambassador,
creating a pathway that would take
these skills into the neighborhoods.
Reynaldo came to us and said, ‘would you
be willing to train these ambassadors?’
And I thought, hmmm, here’s an
opportunity for our students.
And Reynaldo and I sat with them and said,
‘would you be willing, under my supervision,
to be the trainers of these ambassadors?’
These men, and one woman, they’ve all been incarcerated,
they’ve all been part of gangs and they want to see that end.
It’s breaking the barriers.  As long as we keep saying
that ‘can’t go here, can’t go there’ you know.
We will always be stuck.  We’ll always be living
that war zone mentality.
Being trained as mediators will help us
deal with a lot of the conflict.
And like I said, the ultimate goal is to help ourselves.
Because if we not in control of ourselves
then we no good.
Helen Keller Park sits at the southern tip of the Vermont Corridor.
Law enforcement calls it ‘death alley’
due to the high homicide rate.
The recklessness of these brazen murders
and assaults shook the community to the core
as residents did not feel safe enough
to leave their own homes.
It’s where the Raymond Crips would
carry out initiations and plot trouble.
Today it’s a focal point for the community.
And for five weeks it’s where the UCLA students worked with people
like Green, Casanova, Snoop and Mott in the art of mediation.
I need to check some ID.  Wait, hold on. (Overtalk).
Why you being so hostile?
(Overtalk)  Can I talk to you a minute officer?
I’m the gang interventionist over here.  They’re just having a friendly softball game. (Overtalk)
But I’m just saying you come over to us and (overtalk).
The first week, they was tensing up. Everybody was
like, OK. Like they didn’t know what to expect.
The next week they come in and they’re more relaxed.  They’re giggling.
And now, we ask the same question and answer
session.  It’s ‘how do you feel today?’
‘Oh, I’m relieved. I thought it was something different.’
Just a stereotype.  You know, we’re not a threat
and people look at us as a threat.
Our students gave, I think, something of great value.
But, they got something great in return,
which was a friendship; because that formed bonds between them.
They would talk very openly and comfortably with each other.
We were no longer the people from UCLA
coming down to train the people in South LA.
It was a two-way street where the students were
getting something of equal if not greater value.
We already know how to talk to our own folks.
But, y’all showed us another way to.
You know what I’m saying.  Without being so hostile,
with eight different communities here on a Saturday,
playing these games, how many lives we just saved.
So, if the baseball games pass without incident
—which I’m pretty sure they will—
Then this all a path, one of many paths
to bring peace to South LA.
With additional funding from the Pete Carroll Foundation,
they played a full slate of games throughout the summer.
We got our ambassadors.  If you have any disputes,
call them to you, talk to them, get that worked out.
UMP: Great.  Appreciate that.  Thanks for your support.
The majority of them have been
trained as ambassadors.
We have an ambassador for every neighborhood
that comes and participates.
And everybody that comes in knows how to deal with
issues on the field, off the field, in our community.
All right home team take the field.
On this Saturday, they played four games.
The talent pool varied widely.
There was plenty of spirited trash talking,
but when the games ended,
it was with sportsmanship and respect.
We come here each week to bring something positive
to all the different neighborhoods.
At one time there was no way any of these neighborhoods
could have got together in this park and did anything.
And now, you can have eight different neighborhoods
in a park at one time; having fun.
We can all take a loss now and it doesn’t have to go to,
“well, I’m gonna go here and get this weapon
and do something to somebody.”
We can say now, “all right, you got me this time.
We’ll get you next time on the field.”
That way we can always come back and continue to
fight the good struggle instead of the bad struggle.
For Buzz, there is no doubt that these
efforts to dial down the violence are working.
Crime statistics offer some evidence to back that up.
And Reynaldo says there are several more
neighborhoods that want to be a part of this.
Putting interventionists, ambassadors and mediators
into the mix is moving the effort forward
with some help from the students of Restoring Civility.
I hope that they, like me, come to a deeper understanding
of South Los Angeles and the people in it.
We don’t understand it. We’re afraid of it.
It does not come naturally to most of us
to walk in that environment.
So, that when they become… some of them are
going to become teachers and counselors,
that they don’t shy away from going to those schools.
That they actually have an understanding of
what those communities have to offer.